who finally a lighter story who could
man lighter but serious in a way not too
serious but I think it's ironic Donald
Trump
remember when Donald Trump said that he
would not play golf as president if you
need a reminder here's a clip I love
golf I think it's one of the greats but
I don't have time
250 rounds that's more than a guy who
plays on the PGA Tour plays Obama or to
get off the golf course and get down
there
everything's executive order cuz he
doesn't have enough time because he's
playing so much golf he doesn't have
enough time to convince Congress that so
I have the greatest stuff but you know
what and I love golf but if I were in
the White House I don't think I'd ever
see Turnberry again I just want to stay
in the White House and work my air so so
Trump was like I don't have time for
golf I'm not going because I'm gonna be
working well it turns out that Donald
Trump's golf trips alone cost the nation
two hundred and fifty five times more
than his salary right so I mean what's
the point
so the actual estimated total is a
hundred and two million dollars to date
that the President of the United States
has that the President of the United
States has spent just to play golf for
no other reasons no other reasons but to
play golf
the president also like to brag that
he's not taking a salary but who needs a
salary who needs a salary when you're
spending this kind of money and most of
the time you're spending this type of
money at a trump facility right so
there's best well documented how the
nation is is actually enriching Donald
Trump privately because every time we go
to merrill ago every time he goes to a
Trump Hotel every time he goes to a
Trump Resort the nation is pay our
taxpayer dollars are paying millions of
dollars into his personal and
professional golfers and and
conservatives seem to have no problem
with this whatsoever because they're not
concerned about the detail they're
concerned about the political win always
remember that they don't there's they
don't see anything as hypocrisy because
for them the ends justify the
means so if that means they have to
ignore the fact that the president has
played golf more than probably any other
president history certainly more golf
than Barack Obama and the cost of his
trips represent two hundred and fifty
five times his annual salary then what
good is as the fact that he's not taking
this salary but yet they'll still brag
they were still conservatives will still
get online and brag about the fact that
he's donating his salary well yeah he'll
I would donate my salary too if you were
spending 102 million dollars on trips
for me to go around and play golf and I
don't even like golf but I digress
it just speaks to where we are in this
country man we're really we're really in
a place where the truth does not matter
we're in a place where facts don't
matter it this this is irrelevant news
this honestly and in the broader scheme
of American politics today where we are
with Donald Trump this is irrelevant
news however if you take this exact
story fast forward two years two and a
half years when a Democratic president
is in power and they spend 102 million
dollars on a golf trip then suddenly it
would become all the news we know about
this one thing would be enough for
Republicans to impeach a Democrat
because it is grossly irresponsible it
is a gross violation of the monuments
clause I mean he is spending money and
enriching himself on the American
taxpayers dying so this in about three
years would be enough for Republicans to
impeach but today it's barely news see
this is Donald Trump Donald Trump has
the perfect he's like the trifecta has
the trifecta it's probably more but I'm
gonna try to summarize it into three he
has a party that has no backbone and no
spine and they absolutely love the
policies that he's implementing so
they're gonna tolerate it
he has a base that does not care they
will follow him to hell and back again
they would betray Jesus as much as they
try to force Jesus on you they would
betray Jesus on behalf of their master
Donald Trump and he has absolutely no
shame himself
so with that trifecta he can get away
with these types of things
and the news cycle is inundated with his
ridiculousness so much so that there has
been any number of impeachable offenses
that have taken place over the last two
and a half years that if you just take
one Democrat is impeached just one and
yet here we have probably hundreds
literally hundreds of news stories some
some new cycles we don't have even have
enough time right there's some stories
that are important that we don't even
have enough time to cover because we're
so inundated and that's a part of his
strategy that literally is a part of a
strategy and we as a media
infrastructure media arm the Fourth
Estate along with the checks and
balances of the House and the Senate
we were not equipped to combat this type
of onslaught from a president and a
party and a base that are completely
complicit with what he does and with
what he says and so this is how the
President of the United States can get
away with spending 102 million dollars
on golf trips just in about two and a
half years